these surgeons are putting a pig heart
into a human
before this year these types of
surgeries seemed impossible
how this heart ended up here is a
complicated Journey
over 50 years of Innovations made it
possible
and it's all in an attempt to solve a
major problem
not enough organs for transplantation
in the U.S alone it's estimated that one
patient dies every hour as they wait
which takes us back to here to an
operating room at NYU where genetically
modified pig heart beats inside of a
deceased donor and shows no signs of
early rejection
so not only did it not reject but it
actually did its job
the steps happening now at NYU have
really shown to the scientific community
that it's feasible it's possible to
transplant a modified Pig organ into a
human wired spoke with Dr Brandon
goodheart to understand how exactly the
surgery works and why the future of
surgery might look similar
[Music]
for decades scientists and surgeons have
been struggling to come up with
solutions for a huge problem that we
have and that's the shortage of donor
organs every organ unfortunately that's
donated cannot be used we have to be
picky it has to have good function it
has to have appropriate size it's
believed that they're underrepresented
of the actual need by a factor of at
least 10. so in other words for every 10
patients that actually need an organ we
think only about five actually make it
to Medical evaluation and of those only
one will get on the list
xenotransplantation is the transfer or
transplantation of cells tissues or
organs from one species to another it's
a field that has a long history of
experimentation and setbacks however the
last few years there have been huge
leaps forward pioneering heart and
kidney transplants at NYU David Bennett
received the world's first genetically
modified pig heart the first
peer-reviewed research of pig to human
kidney transplantation was public
published and this summer surgeons at
NYU langone transplanted genetically
modified pig hearts into deceased donors
maintained on ventilators it was done
first in a deceased patient really to
prove safety it's really Landmark work
but there's still a lot to know what
we're seeing here is the final step to
understand how xenotransplantation works
we need to go to a lab like this one the
success of xenotransplantation owes a
lot to improvements in The Field's
knowledge of Immunology better testing
better knowledge of tissue and organ
compatibility and better
immunosuppressive regimes have made
organ transplants increasingly effective
it's also LED scientists to an ideal
organ partner initially most of the
early attempts at xenotransplantation
were done in primates for that kind of
logical step of well they're closest to
us we should try that first this
includes a very famous case of baby Fey
who was a newborn in the 1980s that
received the baboon's heart
unfortunately she only lived about 20
days since that time pigs have really
emerged as the ideal donor so doors for
several reasons pigs are very similar in
anatomical size function physiology and
Immunology pigs fortunately grow fairly
rapidly and there are usually adult size
by six to nine months of age crispr cas9
is one tool in a family of tools that
has really changed the game in terms of
our ability to manipulate and edit genes
you can think of as a pair of scissors
and it's able to go in and make cuts and
take pieces of that string or jeans out
and at the same time also insert genes
into the genetic code the technology is
an important tool that solved a huge
hurdle how to bridge 80 million years of
evolutionary differences right now all
of the cases that have been accomplished
have been done with the 10 edit modified
Pig so for instance they've deleted a
gene that encodes for a carbohydrate
marker on the surface of pig cells and
organs you can think of that as a marker
on these organs and cells that tells the
world that this is from a pig other
genes that were added were human genes
and genes that make the organ better app
that dealing with coagulation and
inflammation and swelling and make it
more like us ultimately without these
modifications organs would succumb to
rejection and fail what we found
experimentally even with the highest
levels of immunosuppression essentially
almost turning off the human immune
system these organs will ultimately fail
and so they do need the modification and
and they need to be more like us once
the genes are edited and the organs
grown the next step is matching with a
human donor
most patients will not be eligible for a
human transplant otherwise that's what
they would get second they need to be
strong enough to survive and and make it
through a long complex surgery we also
want their other organs to be
functioning well so that they can
recover well after surgery and then most
importantly it takes an individual
that's brave enough to agree to what
still is an experimental procedure and
understand the risks but potential
benefits that it would carry
which leads us back to here this surgery
is a combination of Decades of research
in multiple Fields the goals of the
surgery were twofold to monitor for
early signs of organ rejection and to
see if the heart could function without
additional support in order for
xenotransplantation to revolutionize our
transplant system these organs have to
function the same or even better than
human organs so the idea of
xenotransplant would be that we'd have
younger stronger better matched organs
and our goal would be that they would
last as long or longer than human organs
the recent advances we've made in
xenotransplant has shown that in the
short term these organs function and
they're safe but what we don't know
quite yet is the longevity will they
last for days months years or decades
and as we saw in the case of David
Bennett incredibly promising but there's
still many obstacles and barriers yet to
overcome rather than transferring entire
organs Dr ginhardt's Lab at Stanford
along with collaborators at Vanderbilt
and Columbia uses Pig organs to revive
and recover damage human organs for
transplant my work has really focused on
a different approach so rather than
taking whole organs and transplanting
them we use the whole pig as a support
system where we take damaged human
organs many of which we've talked about
that just aren't able to be used and
offered to patients and we connect them
to a humanized pig so that that
humanized pig can provide all of the
multi-systems support to allow recovery
in the human organ and provide them
whether it's hours or days time to
recover and allow us to intervene on
that organ to improve it and get it to a
point where we can transplant that human
organ into a patient I think early on
initially the kidneys livers and heart
will be the first organs to successfully
be used in xenotransplantation given
they're a favorable immune profile we
need less immunosuppression less drugs
to drive down our own immune system
conversely I think lungs will probably
be the last Every Breath we take those
organs are in contact with the outside
environment which makes them a very
difficult organ to transplant
the reason xenotransplant successes are
all steps towards clinical trials which
are large-scale research studies that
are rigorously vetted by the FDA
organ transplant is really meant to
provide patients Decades of life not
just years or days and so we want the
work in xenotransplant to mimic that and
to provide that same longevity I am
excited I think over the next five to
ten years with xenotransplantation what
we're going to see is that more organs
are available and that more transplants
are happening there's a lot of work that
goes into this and I think the whole
scientific Community around the world I
think has now seen the promise of
xenotransplant and is invested in making
it move forward
foreign